well dude i hope you sign a freaking 20
fight contract dfc i hope you get the
biggest names in the world there's a
couple dads eating some chicken
sandwiches right now before you go man
uh
are you not dad bob man before you go
everyone that comes on i give a shoe
that i think represents them these from
my boys at suplex in philly
they're super cool i thought you would
give me some crazy rainbow
i may be wearing some colors right
there's some colors maybe wearing some
color yeah i take some fashion risks man
i mean not like you in high school but
uh
these are for you my man i know read
your thing
some red cakes we got some new ones now
hey
yeah hell yeah
yes sir
you those are your sides my man
yeah
they go with the fit too yeah yeah i'm
like should i take these ones off yeah
they look pretty good
yeah
yeah help you wear those your next fight
man oh [ __ ] bro yeah [ __ ] i'm locking
them up get people on paper safe yes
super thick from my
wallet the big boy
i need everything i get super thick boy